at least 50 people have been injured
after Russia launched a missile attack
on Ukraine's Capital Kiev children's
hospital and several homes were damaged
while an apartment building caught fire
K's mayor says most people were injured
after debris from the intercepted
missiles fell on the Eastern side of the
Dena River Rob McBride has been speaking
to people in Kiev affected by the
missile
attack much of ke was awoken in the
early hours of this morning by
thunderous explosions uh as these
missiles were fired into the City and
the air defenses were intercepting them
with an an amount of debris falling in
different locations especially in the
east of the city such as this
neighborhood where you have uh buildings
have had the fronts blasted in there's
also a kindergarten here that has been
damaged cars burnt with more than 50
people being reported injured the air
defenses especially around keev have
been strengthened since last winter
anticipating more attacks like this by
the Russians as they try to Target
critical infrastructure including the
energy Supply
here all the windows and doors were
blown in and everything was flying
around I ran outside and saw some of my
neighbors injured and covered in blood
many were taken to the hospital this
attack came as President Vladimir zinski
of Ukraine was wrapping up his visit to
Washington with the announcement of a
further $2 200 million doar in military
aid which includes more air defenses but
of course there is the disappointment
about the billions of dollars more in
Aid which is being held up in Congress
and this does seem to be a timely
reminder that Ukraine still faces a long
hard winter ahead Rob McBride Al jazer
ke